si les sondages disent vrai le 19
octobre
aucun des trois chefs n'obtiendrait une
majorité de sièges qui sera le premier
ministre du canada
on ne le saura pas nécessairement lundi
prochain quinze personnes dont une
majorité il ya personne qui gagne c'est
l'univers des gouvernements minoritaires
peu importe le nombre de sièges qu'ils
remportent la convention exige que le
gouverneur général demande d'abord
estives et noir peu premier ministre
sortant d'essayer de former un
gouvernement
mais le chef conservateur a déjà déclaré
que s'il n'a pas le plus grand nombre de
sièges
il ne souhaite pas se maintenir au
pouvoir et d'ailleurs ce serait mission
impossible
justin trudeau refuserait de collaborer
avec stephen harper les russes noces
comme studies et weeds même son cloche
du leader néo démocrate
il est temps de mettre à la porte et oui
je vais le faire à la première occasion
thomas mulcair et justin trudeau deux
agents de changements devront alors
collaboré pour régner malgré une
antipathie réciproque
tout un défi surtout que les deux hommes
dit on ne se parle même pas les sondages
indiquent aujourd'hui que justin trudeau
remporterait le plus grand nombre de
sièges mais sans atteindre le chiffre
magique des 170 pour obtenir une
majorité
il devra donc chercher l'appui du npd
pour obtenir la confiance de la chambre
et gouverner pour ce professeur de droit
l'heure sera au compromis il faut pas
oublier qu'un gouvernement ami viole
majoritaire comme on l'a vu ces
dernières
mais c'est aussi l'imposition pur et dur
d'une ligne idéologique sans nuance le
gouvernement minoritaire
c'est l'obligation de négocier pour
éviter des défusions aller voir encore
failli on imagine difficilement une
collaboration
mais le scénario minoritaire a ses
avantages sur rue pitt e mail kane
ancien président de la chambre des
communes a vécu trois gouvernements
minoritaires de partis qui s'unissent et
font des compromis répondent aux
attentes d'un plus grand nombre
d'électeurs dit il depuis 1921 il y a eu
29 élections fédérales
treize gouvernements minoritaires qui
ont duré en moyenne 18 mois trop court
peut-être plus instable sans doute mais
les électeurs qui auront voulu un
changement seront servis ici john isner
radio canada ottawa